A tube station in London has a problem.
Each month, 15 people are injured on its escalators.
But a surprising solution for the station has emerged.
Wait for it.
Hello everybody and please listen up.
I said to my colleague that my wife was bringing down the two kids...
...to meet me after work.
Take care on the escalator, hold on to the handrail and your luggage.
And he said, "Would Megan mind doing a PA announcement...
...regarding the safety on the escalators?"
She does like a bit of acting so I knew she'd be up for it.
It took several takes to get the perfect recording.
I was really nervous when I was first going to do it...
...but then once I did it, I thought, "This is actually okay."
Research shows that deeper adult voices...
...are perceived by humans as having more authority.
Take care on the escalator, hold on to the handrail and your luggage.
A child's voice wouldn't have that authority...
..but perhaps it's the shock factor.
Megan's announcements have been running at the station for 6 months.
Transport for London says injuries have fallen by almost two thirds.
Do you think adults listen enough to children?
No.
They should listen more to children...
...because sometimes children are right.